hey guys the night pants nation tour is
underway indianapolis you are up next
september 30 through october 2nd
baltimore one night only october 23rd
brea california october 28th all tickets
are available at ryansickler.com go get
yours today the honeydew with ryan
zickler
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome you're on
that's you ryan that's me
actually welcome back to the honeydew
y'all we're over here doing it in the
night pants studios i'm ryan sickler
ryan sickler.com ryan sickler on all
social media
make sure you come out and see me on uh
on
when right on tour here uh the night
pass nation tour is already rolling we
already did uh phoenix thank you to
everybody that came out in phoenix how'd
it go it went great man indianapolis
september 30th through october 2nd
baltimore october 23rd brea october 28th
yeah baltimore bro you been there that's
my hometown of course i know of course
you told me five minutes ago and uh make
sure you subscribe to that youtube where
you can watch all these episodes like
this joel mchale episode over here
patreon also the honeydew with you all
uh listen
it's five bucks a month and so far the
last like three episodes four episodes
we've had a man who fell off listen to
this
a 60-foot cliff okay in the wilderness
real wilderness okay this is not cat
goldwater survived uh paralyzed
quadriplegic for 30 hours in the
wilderness by himself had to learn how
to walk again and everything and he made
it we had another guy
who
was a land surveyor stepped on a stick a
rock popped up spins around turns out
that rock's got two eyes and it's
staring at him and he helps solve an
18-year-old cold case the police go back
there's a bullet hole in between
and the bullet is still in the skull
from 18 years ago they match it to the
boyfriend boom they got him on murder
this just happened in december who the
[ __ ] else in common he's doing that all
right it's five bucks a month and you
get the honeydew ad free a day early and
no additional cost you sign up for a
year you get over a month free all right
that's it there it is all right now you
know what we do here we highlight the
lowlights these are the stories behind
the storytellers ladies and gentlemen
the storyteller here today first time on
the honeydew please welcome joe mchale
everybody welcome to the honeydew joel
thank you thank you for being here thank
you thank you joel this is a nice setup
and the office outside doesn't look at
all like you're the first to stand up oh
well you know i don't want to be it
doesn't look at all like
uh that um terrorists are planning
something it uh
it is very uh like true detective out
there all right we're trying to be
welcoming a little bit you did break our
[ __ ] coffee machine but well i i
don't think i feel like um that's a
an error in design
and i the keurig which
is not problematic for landfills uh wow
this is the soapbox i'm gonna stand on
uh if you put the water in and then you
push it there's a long pause for the
water to heat the water to get it
through long enough to make you think
you did something wrong i was completely
angry i feel like the hotel ones are
instantaneous i'm not a coffee guy i'm
just drinking water i come back you
don't drink coffee no why not i don't
drink it because i always thought as i
was a younger i thought everyone drank
coffee black and then i started seeing
my grandmother put all this [ __ ] in it
and then i would sip and i was like oh
well that's exactly how i would drink
coffee too you have a liquid candy bar
i'm glad i don't [ __ ] do that so i
just stayed away from it do you drink
any caffeine at all yes so my diet coke
is my and t coke zero unsweetened tea no
just diet coke but i can't taste any of
it now it tastes like all of it tastes
like [ __ ] so
so water what is water
tastes like to you or
it doesn't have a taste it has to have
something on it
for me to a sweetness or
my mouth can feel things if that makes
sense i can feel heat so i like
salt is a little bit all sweets are the
same sweet taste if i was a an alien
that was not familiar with texture of
food ice cream being cold
cake cupcakes
it all tastes the same to me all of it
all sweet taste the same sweet all
smells like when your coffee was brewing
over here yeah i can't smell your coffee
but i do smell this poisonous smell in
the air and that's the same smell i
smell whether it's gasoline or someone a
barbecue i walk by the other day it all
smells the [ __ ] same so something's
happening because before i didn't even
have that did your diet change
no you still like the foods that you
like i by memory i will still eat the
foods that i know i like do you drink
no i'm not a drinker i'm a smoker i
smoke weed i don't i drink i don't not
have any drinks right but i'm not a
drink what does wine taste like
right
[ __ ] beer tastes like all of it tastes
the same you could give me an ipa or a
light beer and it's all the same guard
wow yeah so
can we please enough about my bs will
you please plug and promote anything you
like
uh boy
um
i i don't uh watch um star girl that's
on the seat uh that's on the uh
the dc app and cw and um i don't know
i've i've got i should should have
looked up my stand-up shows but uh
is there a website there's go to joel
mchale.com you'll see it and then uh i
don't know watch crime scene kitchen on
hulu it's still there you look good dude
49 you [ __ ] look amazing
thank you amazing
uh that's my um that was my pandemic uh
way to deal with anxiety went into it
just kind of like if i don't exercise
i'm going to
drink all the wine and eat all the steak
and i then i will have a problem right
i'm a bigger problem than i already do
well i'm so glad you're healthy i do
want to say this today um we were
talking before the show norm mcdonald
passed uh i don't normally get to record
episodes and flip them within the week
and i'm glad we are with this one and i
just wanted to say um it's such a sad
day he's a legend everyone loved there's
no one i haven't never heard a bad story
about nor mcdonald they're all
outrageously hilarious and kind and
funny i was glad to be able to meet him
and where'd you meet him um at the
irvine improv i met him um
and uh i'll tell the story here and uh
so i tom segor and i were down there we
had done a show together and then norm
came in to do one behind us
and
his opener was going to be up for like
30 minutes and it was frank back in the
day at irvine the old irvine okay and um
he's like hey norm uh is a big weed
smoker do you have some weed i go you
have some weed and he's like will you
take him outside and get him high go
sure if he's comfortable doing that
before right before he goes up okay i
don't like to do that and i smoke weed i
i don't mind doing it before a podcast
because i'm listening to you but if i've
got a structure in my head
i i feel like it throws it off even if
it's that much it's my timing i can't
you know i can't drink before a show
right because i feel like it's playing
basketball or something and i'll uh uh i
know some guys it activates and
works well yeah
but so you went outside so tom uh norm
and i go outside and i'm i'm a bit ocd i
like things clean i like things neat and
i had just cleaned this bowl that i had
this glass but i just cleaned it and
most people when you back in the day
before a pandemic if you borrowed a bowl
from somebody it was you were sucking
through that dirt and your lungs you're
gonna pass out before you get high
because your oxygen's running low but
this thing is hitting
like it's brand new okay
and how do you clean it by the way um i
take rubbing alcohol salt and water and
i heat it on increments in the microwave
in a little like microwave safe dish
about seven to eight seconds
um and then i boil uh boil it and then
it'll get real loose in there and i take
pipe cleaners and just poke it through
wow that's it not joking around no okay
so this pipe is but i have just done
this it is it is brand-new
and i tell norm
you know this is some really good
[ __ ] weed
and
don't rip that pipe i just cleaned it
and he's like all right how are you
doing he's a big weed
so he packs the [ __ ] thing we're out
in the parking lot right in the middle
everything
and he takes this [ __ ] hit and i just
look at tom like holy [ __ ] he's a cloud
comes out of him he's coughing he's
crying and he's like oh my god i [ __ ]
told you not to rip it that hard dude
i'm telling you
and then he starts laughing and we start
talking about the british office
and he and i connect
so hard on the all the little
idiosyncrasies of ricky gervais in the
british office and we're dying and
talking about um
all these little moments we love and
then he goes in and he's [ __ ] up
and um he did one hit he didn't know he
did more than one hit he just did that
one like it was like he was going to
space and continued to smoke but and
then the [ __ ] security comes up they
see it it's a clown you know we're we're
right in the middle right out front you
know what i'm talking about so the guy
comes up and we're like oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
you know we're not supposed to be doing
this out here like this it's a it's like
a saturday night there's families out
there and the guy comes up and thank god
he recognized but he didn't at first he
recognizes norm he goes hey man you
can't be doing that oh oh hey hey hey
you can't be doing that like it went
turned real quick he goes this guy gave
me the weed i'm like this [ __ ]
he's like all right we're going inside
so he goes inside
and frank's like did you get him high i
go yeah but he got like really [ __ ]
high and then norm just to be a dick's
like i don't know what he gave me frank
but i'm pretty sure sickler gave me some
lace [ __ ] he's like you came laced weed
i'm like i would never smoke laced weed
i did not do that and then he went up
there
and i'm telling you joel this
[ __ ] improved
a good five minutes on the drink slice
because the improv had pepsi at the time
and it wasn't sprite it was slice
remember that drink slice and he [ __ ] on
slice for like five [ __ ] minutes it
was the funniest [ __ ] i've ever heard
and i think that was enough to sort of
get him back uh reset and then he just
ran and crushed yeah it was great it was
great how long was his show
god he probably did an hour and a half
wow yeah he would go for a while
yeah there's only i feel like i mean i
only met him a couple times so then it's
one of those things that everyone's like
he was the nicest guy
and then
and he was such a powerful influence
you know when he got on weekend update
it was like the lights turned on yeah
the whole oj thing of kicking them off
or [ __ ] on oj too much and his his
horrible bert reynolds that was the best
burt reynolds ever turd ferguson yeah so
good that whole [ __ ] on out on jeopardy
just the best larry king
and then his appearances on talk shows
they they reminded me of like a jeff
goldblum like
like you're like nobody is made like
that it's just it was like that per like
when you talk about you think i can make
it then you see a person like that i was
like that person's going to be famous
because they are so unique and so
talented and
it just reminds me of this time he uh
conan was interviewing courtney thorne
smith from
a zillion different things and he was
the he had been the lead guest and was
still on the couch and
and uh she was promoting
a movie with carrot top in it that she
had done
and conan goes what's the name of the
movie and then norma's like i i i i know
the name of that movie and it was with
kara top right she's like yeah he's like
uh box office
and then
and then
yeah
and then she's you can clear and then
yeah she's
conan's like she's in the movie you know
that uh-huh and then and then she goes
no it's called chairman of the board and
he goes board is spelled b-o-r-e-d
and conan you guys like snot shooting
out of his nose yeah there's no way he's
gonna hold that in right like
you're yeah
like
her poor you just maybe was like you
know you're walking out there's an
assassin sitting next to you
because he is going he is so clever and
so quick
oh but 61. my lord young
it was so it was so shocking
we were talking but like i didn't i
didn't know he was sick yeah that's the
other thing i feel like people are doing
that these days they're keeping their
sickness to themselves and and then you
find out at the last minute and then
they're quickly they're gone yeah
chadwick boseman was the same way yeah
uh well love to uh
norm's family and friends for sure it is
a he is a icon yeah no doubt boy what a
what a
just a titan in them for comedy for so
long
um so let's talk about you here i i do
want to get into some things with you
because um i ask everyone to send their
list and your list had a few things on
it but dyslexia yeah we're going to get
into some some very scary [ __ ] later too
but the selection is something oh yeah
yeah that eye
i don't know that we've had um
we've had a few people have come on but
i don't know that they've really
it's been this thing for them in a way
so yeah let's go back to the beginning
because this starts when yes does this
come from another a parent uh well uh it
came from my dad but he doesn't really
admit it
and because it's past because he's that
generation of dads yeah he was like i
don't think so my mom's like oh she
can't spell and uh
yeah i mean he married my dad was very
smart and married um my mom who it was a
newspaper editor so what did your dad do
he did a lot of things but eventually he
had his own executive head hunting
company
uh which he he was he he probably should
have been like an artist because he can
do sculpture and drawing and stuff but
uh
but he was a businessman but eventually
he was like i found out what i'm good at
i was like what he's like talking to old
rich men
and that's you know executive hand
hunting is that and uh so that worked
and uh he did well and
but he needed my mom to like proofread
and all that stuff like just like i need
my wife to do that on mine still you do
oh well i send texts to people and
they'll be like are you drunk i'm like i
i didn't read it click carefully
and yes i'm probably drunk probably uh
but i yeah it was
i knew earlier my older brother also has
it my younger brother definitely did not
have it
uh it was such a what because when i
finally like started like you think
you're just the three of you siblings
yeah okay uh but i figured out well one
of us i ate my twin in utero and uh yeah
twins do that you were a twin no um
i was gonna say were you about to be one
you snuffed them out just
took the umbilical cord and wrapped it
around
i don't wanna be the only one coming out
uh
i was c-sectioned uh but uh uh and then
my mom was told after she had me that
there's no way
that you're gonna have another kid with
everything that happened down there and
then she got pregnant again and then the
doctors she didn't believe the doctors
and she kept on drinking and smoking and
then my little brother came out and he
was the smartest one so he went to the
good he went to like a good school so
anyway that said
uh
i clearly was not a great student and
continue to not be but
i you know the school system as it was
and continues to be
is
geared for a certain kind of student and
uh it's a very narrow
uh slice of
uh
speaking of slice uh it's a narrow slice
well done students but i i got held back
uh i was in a thing called translational
let me if you don't mind let me
interrupt for a second i was held back
in high school now what when do you
first realize you
like this shit's i'm i'm having trouble
with this
where was it before you're held back
uh i i didn't even think about being
held back i i was always in like the
i don't i i just uh it was so early on
that they realized i couldn't really
read
uh that they are already putting me in
like the special kids classes and i
remember in third grade we would always
like a group of us would go to this
other part and while the other students
were learning cursive they were like
what did you do like we made paper mache
monkeys and uh i remember i remember
just like i was doing art projects and
uh i always so i knew i couldn't read i
never thought about what it was a
diagnosis or anything like that well
you're a kid so yeah so i'm just like
but also you say you're not a great
student was it because of this learning
disability or were you also
acting out in class and all that were
you a bad kid or are you just not a good
student not a good student okay but
obviously you can uh
you must love that
that's gonna be great for your ocd
stay there it's on your pants i'm good
this table is a whiskey drinking weed
smoking today we could scratch this all
up you just [ __ ] spit that's great
wow i like how
you hate that coffee dude i'm drinking
it all d it's it's not good coffee but
it's
it's drinkable
uh it's what we have it's what we have
do you have any melon star yeah plenty
of it really yeah no one wants honeydew
we have crates of it bro crates yeah i
can't stand it uh i feel like it's they
take a lot of cantaloupe and honeydew
and round out every fruit bowl with
that's the whole point yeah and then you
eat around it and leave that [ __ ] and
bounce yeah imagine just the perfectly
good fruit thrown away yeah that's
what's all about it should be eliminated
from the planet
okay before we talk about oh right so
uh
i began i just so i was like so i i kind
of felt like
i think i know i'm funny and people like
me i like them i'm a terrible student
all these other kids are getting a's
um
and uh you know but i have so i started
just cheating that's how i got around
everything and i cheated all the way
through heist i mean high school and
college you did all the way through yeah
i'm not pr i mean whenever i do college
gigs and i get interviewed by the
student paper i'll be like yeah i
shouldn't have gone to college and uh i
was like i definitely should have
skipped it university of washington
that's a big school though well yeah
it's basically how do you get in you
don't do you have to take sats oh yeah
yeah
850 on my sats and that was see
thank you make me feel good i had my
first one though this makes me feel so
good this makes me feel so good what'd
you get i got at 860.
and i was like ryan sickler step your
[ __ ] up you're a 3.0 student you're
better than that i don't test well but
[ __ ] that we're going to do it again and
i did and i improved and i got a 870.
look at that boy
this community college for me that's
well
i
my grades in high school like i started
with a 1-4
in like the first quarter my mom was
like what is happening
and i was like don't worry it's gonna be
great and then by senior year i was
averaging like a three nine three eight
because i damn you cheated that well oh
i was so good at it what were your
techniques
uh i would find i would sit next to the
right people i may make deals
um i had a friend that would always
finish before me with alphabetical order
matt schilling sh msi
still we've been friends since
kindergarten and he went to princeton
like i knew
he was the right guy he would slide that
paper like this and then he would just
sit at his desk after he was done like
that i'll be back there like
yeah and i just thought ah the american
education system that it
yeah but i um i would also if you they
allowed to have scratch paper i would
just uh
well when i was on in college i could
get the tests in advance because i
played football
and they had all the tests so you played
for washington not well i was a walk-on
but still you were playing yeah
i was practicing position tight end okay
i was really good at getting hit by the
defense i made them feel so good about
themselves
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our first sponsor upstart if you
dread looking at your credit card
statements you are not alone debt can
feel crippling but upstart can help you
on your path to financial freedom
upstart is the fast and easy way to pay
off your debt with a personal loan all
online whether it's paying off credit
cards consolidating high interest debt
or funding personal expenses over half a
million people have used upstart to get
one fixed monthly payment upstart knows
you're more than just your credit score
and is expanding access to affordable
credit unlike other lenders upstart
considers your income and current
employment to find you a smarter rate
for your loan within a five minute
online rate check you can see your rate
up front for loans between one thousand
to fifty thousand dollars and you can
receive your funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com honeydew that's
upstart.com honeydude don't forget to
use my url to let them know i sent you
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit your income and certain
other information provided in your loan
application go to upstart.com honeydew
our next sponsor is expressvpn now going
online with that expressvpn it's like
using a public toilet without shutting
the door everybody's going to know your
business all right so it doesn't take
much technical knowledge to hack someone
just some cheap hardware a smart 12 year
old could do it your data is valuable
guys hackers can make up to a thousand
dollars per person selling your personal
information on the dark web it's very
easy to use okay you fire up the app you
click one button to get protected it
works on all your devices your phones
your laptops your tablets and more so
you can stay secure on the go look we
use expressvpn we use it here at the
studio i use it at home uh it makes me
feel safe secure and we haven't had any
problems all right so here's what you
need to do you need to secure your
online data today by visiting
expressvpn.com
honeydew that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n
slash honeydew and you can get an extra
three months for free expressvpn.com
honeydew now let's get back to the do do
you can i ask you about any times like
when you were a kid when they would make
you guys read aloud and things like that
would you do you remember anything oh
yeah i always say [ __ ] oh spelling bees
and reading a lot about spelling bees
spelling bees were just
i mean
it was
not i'd be like they'd be like
uh choke and i'd be like yes that's what
i'm doing right this is gonna happen
right now and uh
and it's funny because i like i was i
was joked around in class i was liked in
class i'm obviously very social i am a
golden retriever
in that way but then they would hear me
smell and be like what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you and i'm like i don't know and
so yeah i wasn't i was you know i was
ashamed of it no doubt but i so i was
just like i'm going to get around this
and i'm going to beat this system
and i did you beat it all the way
through did you get a bachelor's degree
i got a master's you got a man
the masters was in like acting and
performing so that that was when you
can't cheat it yeah you can't read the
one thing you don't have to read i guess
yeah and people like oh can you not
memorize i was like that has nothing to
do with this that's what i was going to
ask you too how do you have trouble
reading scripts and putting it into
memorization no memorizing is easy okay
it's the
reading of the script that just takes
longer got it so when my agents will be
like they're interested in you for this
movie and i'll be like did you read it
because i haven't i'm i go unless you
think it's good for me i'm not gonna
read it and and then and then they'll go
it's a good thing you should do it and
then i went set the meeting
and i'll that will give me that will
force me to read it because i'm also my
attention is all over the map uh so that
that's how i usually uh do those
reads but uh or do do those meetings but
um so i read much slower but my
comprehension is off the charts okay
what about actually writing when you
like sit down to write jokes or material
do you actually still write or do you
type and and what is that i have uh
notebooks i'd write everything out
what's easier for you reading or writing
well writing is also like a [ __ ] show
because i'll leave out words i'll
misspell everything if you look at my
my joke book it looks like the ravings
of a lunatic because it'll just say like
penis
uh and then it'll be like iowa is dumb
and
if i'm in iowa
so then the other thing i don't write
out jokes word for word i go
like if i'm doing and also i never write
jokes because i also have terrible
attention and don't concentrate but when
i get a gig i'll be like oh i'm going
there like i just did ohio university in
athens uh ohio and i was like okay so
i'm going to have i know i got to do
like a half an hour new material about
them so that i'll scramble on the plane
and write out all that stuff so it i no
test have i ever prepared for in advance
really ever uh and so but the true test
i was always like if i'm in a play
like in a shakespeare play like
you better know that [ __ ] when you walk
out on stage and
so i've never like on stage i've never
forgotten my lines i've i've been in
plays where people go up and they forget
them and
then i then we're a good time and then
it gets very funny uh do you have
anxiety about any social media posts or
spelling things incorrectly oh my i will
post something and my wife will be like
here's what you screwed up and then i
have to go back and fix it
the weird part is that nobody notices
hardly and i'm like hey also they're
just as dumb as me care these days most
people don't care
that
which unfortunately people don't know
the difference between there they're
there you know these things but they
also don't seem to give a [ __ ] or were
and we're right
no yeah i mean it's it's an interesting
it is it's like you shouldn't be okay
with that but i appreciate it yeah yeah
you know my wife is she's so smart and
so she corrects everything i'm
i yeah so i'm i thank god
so it's great so anyway dyslexic still
today oh yeah you don't with a master's
degree well yeah but that wasn't
whatever it's still it's still for the
soup it would take when i started the
soup it would take me four hours to get
through 22 minutes of jokes so uh is
that from prompter or prompter which i
could not read and i had tons of anxiety
about that to this day
i have to know it in advance but the
anxiety
thankfully has gone down for dyslexia at
least
and
that and i got to a point on the soup
where we were doing it live
and yeah we would promote it because
there was a time when i was ashamed of
it and especially in school where i'd be
like i'm just gonna get around this by
joking and playing sports and doing
acting um but then when the soup came on
and then we started doing shows live
i would promote it by saying i'm
dyslexic so i don't know what i'm going
i don't know what's going to happen
and that made you know that was
very liberating and to have the pressure
of live
the live television happening
it really is in the you know it took me
years to kind of be really comfortable
that's why
when i see
like hosts starting off and they're
already great i'm like oh [ __ ] that was
not me
and uh thank god like the first year of
the soup nobody watched and
and then i got good and comfortable at
it and then it
aren't you the longest tenured host on
there too weren't you the longest yeah
everyone else left right but no but
still they did everyone everyone left to
do other things that's why they left
yeah i mean most of them you know
obviously aisha john they all and kaneer
left originally yeah
i was just like hey they're offering me
if i can do this once a week and still
do community or a movie then i'm gonna
i'm taking the money and i'm because and
also i enjoyed the hell out of it so of
all the gigs community
um
the soup those things what was the most
difficult then this would it be the
prompter reading of the soup because you
could memorize your community lines and
well i mean there was different
uh advantages and disadvantages to both
obviously community was community and
i couldn't believe i was on such a good
show awesome uh but the hours were
bananas and i didn't see my kids you
know when they were little i just lived
at their you know i oh look
uh they're it's happening again no uh
so
uh no they they so that was that was
rough there but you know we loved each
other on that uh in that cast and so
that was but the soup yes that the
prompter was rough and the
and uh i mean i had the staff was so
good that we were in a good rhythm you
know as as the years went on um so
uh and that gig i mean i would go to
community get my makeup on go to e for
four hours do the soup and then go back
to community oh [ __ ] okay yeah and
because we were working like that yeah
we were working 80 hour weeks
we were always working overnight on
fridays where we started at 6 a.m on
monday and then we kept going long until
we had to finish the episode or get
close to it so we would end at 8 a.m
on saturday morning and then i would
miss flights to the east coast go do
stand up because i am a workaholic
maniac so these are all luxurious
problems but
uh i'm very thankful to e for because i
learned really learned how to read
without anxiety wow and so but like when
i still on television on television
on your shoulders but
yeah yeah but i don't think i would have
i needed that sort of fire under my ass
because i wouldn't have done it that's
how it is with most of my i like the
motivation and like when i book a
stand-up show i'd be like you have this
thing coming up you better be prepared
for it and then it forces me to prepare
it's great do you remember any good
system for life guys that's my tony
robbins like
first get the gig be totally unprepared
and at the last second freak out and
then run on stage for an hour that's how
you get rich yeah it's rich um is there
any moment
that sticks out from like
adolescent school that really was just
so embarrassing
i had this friend from baltimore and he
was a real
they all are best they are embarrassing
that like something that sticks in your
mind that you to this day you remember
about your dyslexia and and how it
affected you
i was in a play in fifth grade it was
more of a so it was it was on stage but
it was reading we weren't we weren't off
book and
uh and we i forget what the play was it
was like we're doing a stage reading and
they knew i liked acting and they knew
in class that i was
a very animated student um and they were
like joel you'll be great for the lead
and i
was in uh so but then we would do the li
and i was like this is gonna go great
and it was a [ __ ] disaster and then
the next day i couldn't be there in this
guy named kevin rooney who i'm friends
with today who lives in pittsburgh uh go
seahawks what uh go ravens no uh
no go see no and so he did he read my
part the next day and they're like man
kevin was so much better i like you know
like i feel like he read all the words
he knew all the words he nailed like he
could read yeah it was like it wasn't
just a guy um
mumbling around uh yeah i mean those
some of those soup things i remember
john oliver appeared in the beginning
so some days would be good in some days
it would be bad he appeared on
on
the soup and we were in new york and he
was like what is going on i'm like oh
i'm horribly dyslexic and it's like you
have kept this a very good secret i'm
like yeah uh
but that so that i'm trying but there
wasn't a moment where people like
judas you know there wasn't like a thing
like that i just felt
stupid
and it always like it breaks my heart
because so i literally because i think
about all the kids out there that are in
these education systems that are
designed for a certain kind of student
that is a very narrow slice again uh and
there's all these smart interesting kids
that uh
are
[Music]
i'm sure they feel stupid and because i
felt stupid and i was told in second
grade that i was a slow starter
and a teacher told you that a like a
person that ran studies on me like
because my parents are like what's wrong
with them and uh they were like he's a
slow starter i mean literally told me i
was slow
but i kind of took that to
you forget what affects you as a kid and
i was like okay
so that means i start off slow but
towards the end i'll pass that strong
finisher yeah so you know like in high
school like i ended up like getting
almost straight a's because i figured
out how to work their system and i but
that
you know that like mentality when i
moved here i'm like i'm gonna figure
this thing out i'm not just gonna i'm
gonna figure out how to get
uh to work to be solvent in this
business i'm gonna figure it out and
that's
so that definitely made me work harder
and all that but the shame and the
feeling stupid sucked and is bad and i
feel so bad for all the kids out there
that
uh you know and i can't stand it when i
see every like every commercial and
every
school and every business goes like
we're thinking out of the box we're
doing all these things and it's always
the exact opposite you you figured out
how to do math a different way and [ __ ]
all the parents up that's what you
[ __ ] did
yeah so yeah i was terrible at math too
geometry was fine i could do that
strangely like literally had a math
teacher go
hey man you're like algebra he would he
was took such pity on me and uh but and
this he was a great um teacher mr
simpson simpson and um he he was he i
was so good at uh he was like are you
cheating at geometry i'm like i'm
actually not ever if you can believe
that i've cheated everything else
then trigonometry was so bad uh that guy
was and it just fell off that was like
another language for me it really was
math once it got beyond
geometry and in algebra 2 and you got
letters and [ __ ] a's and b's and x's and
y's i'm like i'm done
no and i
for yeah i don't i mean that is not
thank god for those people because they
built everything yeah uh but i when i
got to college
i had to take a class for no credit
it was a math class it was a high school
math class in college to get into
college math
uh so i was taking this in college and
like they lit i looked at my mom was
like you're not taking a full schedule
i'm like no no no look i'm taking four
classes this one's just not worth
anything and she's like why and she goes
because i couldn't get out of high
school math that was the one like was
hard to cheat in high school math um
and so
i was flunking the col the high school
college course and the teacher was like
the high school college yeah the high
school math college course to get into
college i was already in college i mean
this is a time when the university of
washington was easy to get into sorry
university of washington but it was much
easier back then now i know when i tell
people like oh good for you i'm like you
got in with that 860.
or yeah
or whatever you had this equation
that worked and they're like great uh
does he have money yes yeah but it was
it was in-state tuition right but i the
teacher little the math teacher was like
um hey are you gonna like he pulled me
aside he's like you're not he's like are
you gonna take a degree that requires
math and i was like [ __ ] no i don't want
to be i want to get out of here he was
like okay good i'm going to pass you do
not take math
and i was like advising you not to do
this and i did and then i took that's a
good teacher though me yeah it was good
i had to do one matter i took the
philosophy of logic which i realized was
actually harder and i just i just i got
the test in advance and would just very
lightly
write the answers out on the scratch
paper
and then i i always made sure that i got
b minuses
plus b minuses don't overdo it don't
ever don't draw attention to it is kids
acing it no i remember being in that
class and a girl was cheating and she
got caught and was thrown out of school
and i was like
yeah it was a big deal in college when i
went to towson um they had uh i remember
it was a yellow [ __ ] letter that went
out to every person that it was all
about cheating yep all about cheating
and how you'll be there are no second
chances you're out all that wow all
right so here's what i want to know
you're a parent obviously now how many
kids do you have two boys okay
have you passed
your dyslexia on yes i have
to both you're welcome eddie
one of them
kind of has some a little bit but eddie
definitely has it but he's what are they
16 and 13. okay eddie is a like a math
whiz eddie's 16 or 13. 16. okay he
definitely has it oh yeah he definitely
has it and he when he got diagnosed
because we had him tested
at the
the
the woman who did the testing the doctor
she was like she'd start describing all
his symptoms and like all the the things
that are dyslexic i'm like oh that's uh
that's me and she was like oh yeah i was
wondering which one it was
and uh because i hadn't never gotten a
fully like
real diagnosis i just kind of knew it
um so you're getting it but through your
son's diagnosis yeah but i'm like oh and
she's like oh okay great but
uh so anyway that's a really nice gift i
gave them uh and are there new things
now do you see an advancement in the
teaching or understanding in the however
many years it's been since you were in
high school there's no cure no i don't
mean that but i mean are there better
ways to understand this and teach kids
and help them better than just being
like don't do math here's a b
well there are better there are ways but
traditional
american educational systems still still
don't [ __ ] pretty much the same [ __ ] but
there are all sorts now it's like
celebrated like like there's the
dyslexic advantage book there's there's
ways to read on a kindle that will read
aloud to you while it highlights the
words
there's all these cool
like you'll never get cured of it but
you can
figure out methods and
uh way to ways to proceed that you can
get better and faster at it okay no
doubt and i am such a compared to what i
was the prac i mean just like anything
practice as well there are apps that
really you can go through and transition
you know to see things a different way
or things
some people like wear sunglasses no joke
they'll wear a blue lens or a yellow
lens you just never know um i when
audible and that helps with the some for
some kids oh wow i mean and what would
be great if a school is like allow kids
to read i mean uh allow kids to have
their just more time to read but with
audible i gone back and read all these
classic books because
you know they were all assigned i read
none of them
but you know like read all dostoyevsky
because it's great other than having to
keep track of all the names and the
nicknames uh but that i've gone back and
it's been a revelation and i tear
through books now
uh i was talking to jack shepard does
the same thing where it's all the way
that's how i get like people i it's
people like what podcast you listen to
and i was like
definitely not the honey duke but
but no i'm like i just read book i mean
now it's just i feel like i'm catching
up and it's so glorious to to read all
these books that i never read
that's great i love that you've gone
back and done it not just and looked at
it like this thing like eh
no yeah i love it it's also inspiring to
your kids to see you know especially
that you've struggled with this and you
still struggle with this that that's
that's yeah i think that's important i
mean they're just as sarcastic as i am
so they're like thanks [ __ ] yeah
appreciate this gift dad yeah
yeah no and my my mom when i start
bringing it up like if i bring up like
when we were talking about eddie to her
about his dyslexia she was and i'd be
like and i have dyslexia and then my mom
always gets really defensive and she was
like well
you did okay for yourself
no mom i'm not because she i think she
thinks it's her fault and i'm like dad
you haven't he's like ah i don't know
and i was like you you know and then
they'll admit but my mom always bursts
out crying i'm like it's okay she did a
bad job
i'd be like yes but i do even though i'm
driving a turbo s porsche it's gorgeous
i i definitely can't read that fast
yes do i have a guest house yes mom
that's true
you haven't paid for dinner since 2005.
all that is true and it's gone well
thank god but
listen
you definitely i definitely don't read
fast my older brother has it too and
he's an electrician so but that doesn't
i mean obviously it requires reading but
he spends most of his time trying not to
blow himself up
yeah you've had you've really taken
an occupation that has certainly
challenged your [ __ ] weakness
yeah no and again and i i uh i have that
is my
uh probably my suicidal wish is that
that's what i mean but i love i mean i
love standing on stage and i love that
pressure i love
you know that feeling there's there's
nothing better i mean i i it's instant
good or bad it's immediate it's not yeah
i shot this movie it'll be out in a year
or we did this podcast it'll be out in a
week or whatever it is immediate
feedback in the [ __ ] room good or bad
and that's immediately nothing like that
there is yes it is the high that i
crave and i i mean i love acting i mean
that was my first love uh and so i love
seeing i do love that process and
figuring that out
but that that wonderful pressure
is just i crave it
uh i got
ohio university i was like i wanted to
hug every one of them because i'm so
happy that crowds are back and
vaccinated i hope
[Laughter]
crazy people let's take a quick break
and tell you about our spots are purple
doesn't it seem like the world's against
us from getting a good night's sleep
this time of year especially now it's
hot sweaty you got that neck sweat going
on but when you have a purple mattress
you can sleep cool and comfortable no
matter what the world throws at you
that's because only purple mattresses
have the grid its unique ventilated
design allows air to flow through to
help you sleep cool even when it feels
like a thousand degrees out and the grid
is amazingly supportive for your back
and legs while cushioning your shoulders
neck and hips no matter how you sleep
unlike memory foam which remembers
everything the grid bounces back as you
move and shifts so you never get that
i'm stuck feeling you do with memory
foam all right
their pillows are great too i got a
pillow they sent me a pillow one of the
best pillows i've ever had i'm a side
sleeper i sleep on it i flip it over
this thing stays cool on both sides the
whole night long alright so try your
purple mattress risk free with free
shipping and returns financing is
available too purple is comfort
reinvented right now you'll get 10 off
any order of 200 or more go to
purple.com honeydew and use promo code
honeydew that's purple.com honeydew
promo code honeydew for 10 off any order
of 200 or more purple.com honeydew promo
code honeydew terms apply our next
sponsor is fitbod now if you're like me
i'm a guy that i i get bored with the
workouts i you know i do the same things
over and over i get stuck you plateau
you burn out
and i don't want you to get stuck doing
the same workouts all right you can make
progress toward the future you and that
means overcoming new challenges fitbot
creates a fitness program that
continually adapts with new exercises
and dynamic intensity to adjust to how
you're progressing so
you'll be challenged to meet your goals
at your own pace there's no perfect body
that everyone can achieve but what we
can do is continually become a better
version of ourselves all right i'll tell
you what i like about the app all right
i set it up last night i'm going on the
road if i don't have any equipment
there's a whole
workout for no weights okay um there's
if you don't know how to do an exercise
there's a video to show you how to do an
exercise you can include warm-ups pre
and post
you can just say hey i just want to do
chest today or you know what i want to
do chest tries and calves and boom boom
boom your whole workout is laid out
there for you all right and like i said
if there's no equipment no worries fit
body has body weight routines for those
looking to get it fit at home or on the
go fitbot is super easy to use and even
has hd video tutorials to make learning
new exercises a breeze and integrates
with other fitness and health apps like
apple health fitbit and strava all right
pick up the pace on your fitness journey
with fitbit today and your future self
will thank you get 25 off your
membership at fitbo dot me slash
honeydew that's 25 off at fit bod dot me
slash honeydew now let's get back to the
do well let's talk about you being a dad
because there is something i i want to
hear this story yeah i saw it on your
social not too long ago it was an
anniversary i think maybe or you posted
of it or something you were
bringing
for it was a different it was another
podcast
joe rogan
uh no it's a smaller show
yeah no it was it was this uh it was
like this meditation podcast where they
you just they had they write out you i
kind of told them my story and then
they're like we wrote it out for you and
then i i did my version and they just
kind of do like this is what happened
and so they posted that and i had never
i had talked about it but i had never
sort of laid it out and uh and then i
you know i wanted to ask eddie i was
like hey is it okay if i talk about it
because he's 16 now
and uh and he doesn't mind um because i
pay him every time
jerk
uh so yeah it was uh so my son had open
heart surgery when he was two months old
and uh months two months yeah
it was this is your firstborn firstborn
and you're a brand new [ __ ] dad yeah
when what do they tell you why does he
have to have this well he because you're
home at this point you're obviously well
yeah and and but we
so my wife um
she had post uh postpartum
and you know like as a new mom you're
wanting to feed your child and he wasn't
really latching on
to her nipple and then
they were like it's going to be fine and
we're trying all these different ways
and he's a very skinny kid
at that point and then she reads failure
to thrive on like the charts and she
just glanced at it and that sent her and
me into like oh [ __ ] and
so we bring him home and he eats a
little bit but he keeps falling asleep
every time he eats like he'll start
eating and then just sleep and i'm like
that was that's is that normal and then
people like yes your baby but it would
be in like 10 seconds or less and
then she took him to you know for a
checkup and
the doctor just heard uh that the
heartbeat was not normal
uh and we went right to a uh
cardiologist or a heart specialist and
they put the thing up there and there
was yeah and there was a two two month
old baby heart and people were gonna
miss that yes this thing here oh and uh
that how big is the heart for real oh
and a baby oh yeah two months later oh
yeah like a walnut god and
uh yeah i don't know how people it's not
even that's what i'm saying how do you
it's not even big enough to work on i
feel like yeah we it feels like that and
then they do something you guys are
eating the sam watching doing it and
[ __ ] like that oh no i got this yeah
well that is yeah because once they
we when we had well we the guy i'll get
to that but
the guy was like oh yeah he needs it and
he they're not you're born with holes in
your heart but they close as you're at
like in the first couple months there he
was like this is huge he'll be
this will be irreparable damage by the
time he's
uh four between four and eight and he'll
be probably dead by 20.
and
you just can't you just can't it's just
too much just too much stress on
something damaged like that
and um this is where i learned that
sleep deprivation is the finest of
tortures because we had they're like you
have to feed them every four hours and
you have to feed
and the feedings because he was so weak
would take two hours so but it had to be
every four hours so you'd feed for two
hours another two hours to go by you're
like time to feed again
and that was around the clock and i was
doing the sioux for how long two months
wow that so they
we were just like we were i remember
trying to i was driving home from
e
at i was living in we lived in glendale
at the time and i would see people on
the highway i would see shapes
and i'd be like i cuz i i don't really
get when i get tired it doesn't manifest
itself with
sleepiness to me i begin to hallucinate
okay and then i was i was having heart
problems like my heartbeat was all over
the place because and then and the
doctor i did all these i did a heart
test and i did all this stuff and he's
like yeah you just need like sleep he
was like when's the last time you slept
eight hours i'm like i don't remember
and
uh
so we took him in
and there was we hadn't you know that he
kept uh we were trying to gain getting
him to gain weight
and he wasn't really gaining weight he's
like we should just do the surgery as
soon as possible so we brought him in to
the la children's hospital which is a
miracle place and um we got this guy
named dr vaughn starnes who was known
for how fast he was
and
uh
he they opened him up i mean when you
give away
yeah it was crazy
crazy times yeah where are you
emotionally
handing your brand new child over to
these people to work because do they
tell you there's a chance this doesn't
work
oh yeah you sign all that stuff
someone talked to you about the risks is
it have they told you hey we're we can
fix this and he'll be fine good to go
and are they telling you that yeah oh
yeah they tell you because he had two
holes which is different than the veins
and the muscle and chambers that aren't
there
there it's the it is the simplest of the
open-heart surgeries if there is i hear
you on that yes uh
so
we and later on when we were in the
recovery floor like meeting kids with
heart transplants the parents said to us
they'd be they'd be oh we were hoping it
was that
and then you realize oh wait i'm
we're the lucky ones here and you don't
think about that and so the with the
veins and the ventricles that's that's
multiple surgeries and
like quality of life can be affected
and how long is this procedure you and
your wife sitting at this hospital
freaking the [ __ ] out waiting oh yeah i
mean you're doing so when the but the
moment when you give away your kid you
know like they start giving him the
drugs to
put him to sleep you're you can't
believe it i mean it's so so surreal and
no no fun
and the you can't i mean all that time
is kind of a blur because i've never
slept but you think about like oh you're
dry you put them in the car seat you're
driving them to the hospital
you're gonna be there we knew we slept
over that night but um
so you give your kid away
and they said it's gonna take about two
hours and
we knew we were sitting in the cafeteria
uh and we're waiting still waiting to
hear how it went and how it's going and
my mom's there and our friend our good
friend the great actor pamela reed is
there
and uh
yeah so we my wife was like well i think
the surgery's over and [ __ ] we're like
how do you know him because because the
doctor's eating a sandwich and uh
that was him he didn't even come over
and say something he didn't well he
didn't see us
okay all right
and well then we learned later on
because the real it takes more to now
they crack the i don't even think they
crack the chest as much anymore now they
just go through the sides but when they
crack the chest that takes all the time
but the actual surgery because this guy
was famous for it continues to be uh was
15 minutes that's it because he's so
fast he goes done and then they
and that closes the valve they close up
because the more time you're open the
more time you're on the ventilator the
more time you're you know but their kids
are so dang resilient uh and
so then it was a success and we you know
we all were crying and so happy
but then there was so they do multi
multiple surgeries a day
and um
the kid who was right after us who was
like
he was like five months old
uh he had a valve replaced a pig with a
pig valve
which didn't work and he died no uh and
cause i remember our you were in there
when they now like told them so we're
all you're all in the same area but
i saw
i just i remember the our doctor going
the the surrounding parts of the valve
or he was like their hamburger i
remember hearing that i went oh actually
he said there was nothing to sow into
and uh there was nothing for it to hold
on to um
so then
we watched
them
why the doctor
starnes walk into the waiting room where
they were and close the door
you know to tell them it didn't work and
their whole family was there the
grandparents and you know it was one of
those like
you're like elevators going up and down
and uh it was just uh
tragic anxiety in my chest right now
thinking about it yeah it was [ __ ]
crazy and then then your kid
then they have this room where all the
kids who are recovering from surgeries
they're all around this one nurse and
the nurse just sits at this desk all
night long
and she's like don't you guys go there's
rooms for the parents to sleep in and it
was they said and it was she was like
this is the one night or two nights
you're gonna be perfectly fine because
i'll be watching your kid the whole time
i'm like great and that was the most
sleep my wife and i had gotten in you
just collapsed we were ju i remember
like no it was a quiet room with no
windows and i was like i want to sleep
here and forever
and uh
and then
ironically
like two like he's still recovering and
they gave him a little bit too much pain
medicine and his heart stopped no what
are you excuse me heart didn't stop you
stopped breathing
and our friend kim
was in there at that time when it
happened and she walked out and she said
eddie's not breathing we run in
of course and what they do is they give
you this counter medicine that removes
all the
pain medicine and then eddie woke up
like they were like he's going to feel
he's going to be real pissed in a second
and he was
because he was in pain you know like
yeah
[ __ ] it happened buddy yeah now he's in
me yeah he's two months old two months
old and then
you take you get him home
and this is when you're on the recovery
floor and you realize so like as i said
the parents were saying um
you know like we wish we had that
surgery but then you you're on that
floor and you see little kids with like
bowel replacements and
heart transplants and all the different
organs that kids you know that are
come out damaged or if they don't have
them and then you were like you'd be
like oh
thank you for this version and then when
people are like oh i'm so hard sorry
this happened to you i'm like you know
what it's on the we live in a great city
with a great hospital and we're
you're so fortunate and so lucky and
all that so uh
yeah then then you take him home and you
still have to feed him all the time and
he did you know his energy changed a lot
but you still i was still doing the soup
and
we were still feeding him all the time i
mean having a two-month-old is already
hard as [ __ ] what you have a
two-month-old who's fresh out of open
[ __ ] heart surgery what is that like
being apparent to that you know it's
like you get used to anything
practically and you're there any sort of
um do you have to
uh clean the wound or the stitches or
anything is it like what
do they close you with staples or
stitches yeah
i think they
they use some i mean they use stitches
they have to put the bones back together
some of it's glued back together so his
scar he's got a zipper
but he's got two little places where
like the drainage tube like but they're
not really detectable
anymore and um
[Music]
uh so
you just kind of go like what's the next
step and the fact that he went well was
just kind of like right we got it yeah
and i think the most nerve-wracking
thing was like driving home like don't
get into a car accident and that was
having a child
nothing made me more nervous then
they're like she's yours now go home and
that drive home like i was slowing down
at [ __ ] green lights expecting it to
turn red you know what i mean like oh
god oh god yeah that was really
terrifying to drive a brand new human
person home right all of a sudden the
stakes
went through the roof went through the
roof hadn't gone from nothing to lose to
everything that's why when i see like
dads that ride motorcycles and be like
you're a brave brave person you have a
lot at stake yeah you do uh and i
remember someone saying i was thinking
about getting a motorcycle like in my
late teens and they're like yeah this is
the time to do it
why i was like well you don't have kids
and so you know
if you're dead it doesn't really if the
stakes aren't as high i'm like yeah you
know what i'm not going to give up i'm
just going to pass just not going to
like that shepherd he's still right i
mean he's like a [ __ ] super racer but
he think
he's like put a hole in his shoulder
that was like this big and i was like
good for you man
i can't do it yeah i had a motorcycle
for like two so i kept it for two years
wrote it for like two summers and
i have no i'll never forget the moment i
was like man [ __ ] this we were on the
695 beltway and i'm riding home to my
grandmother's place i'm on this bike
70 miles an hour and i'm right here next
to an 18-wheeler and the tires right
there and that you know that little
float in the middle
and i'm just right next to this thing
and i'm just looking at it like i am
nothing out i am nothing if
if this guy accidentally
i'm done i'm getting sucked done and
that was it for me i was like yeah [ __ ]
this i feel so naked and beyond
vulnerable and i'm hearing that tire
like one one one one right next to it i
was like nah [ __ ] that no way i
there's 18 of them i'm good and i had
you when i got to california i lived in
seattle i grew up in seattle but you
know like when the motorcycle's right in
between traffic
and i was like this is crazy what is
this crazy place how can they do this
and
i i remember
talking to a cop about it i was like
what happens they're like it's mostly
your fault if you merge
so and i'm like what are you doing he's
like st the cop was like stay the [ __ ]
away from them it's
it's it's jarring to not know like i
remember seeing it i i still had my
motorcycle license i just took the
[ __ ] test to take it and i passed it
and i was like oh whatever it's still
class c class m1 but
it says
on the test it's legal
to split the lane but not recommended it
says it right there like you can do it
but we're telling you we don't it's
legal but we don't recommend this and
when you first get here you can't do i
don't know anywhere else you can do that
and these guys come through with those
loud ass [ __ ] heart i've had a beat
on the side of my car if they thought i
was a little too close to their lane
when they go by boom and it's
terrifying yeah what the [ __ ] was that
yeah yeah you got guy i mean and they're
wide harley's dude they're not dirt
bikes squeezing through here these guys
some of them are really [ __ ] good
though some of them well yeah they're
experts they better be good because one
mistake
it's over that's what i think all the
time you're gonna split that lane for 25
miles
you know like [ __ ] that i'm i'm i used
to be a motorcycle rider again very
briefly but even
knowing i had a bike and knowing what's
out there i'm still i've been guilty
sometimes of signaling as i change
right click and i'm going and that's all
it takes for one of these zooms to come
by and you're done and then i just
killed you
right i i killed it i checked my mirror
i mean thank god now for technology
yeah especially out here that's that has
helped me i see that flashing [ __ ]
[ __ ] in the mirror and i'm like oh here
comes a motorcycle that i didn't would
have never seen i had a guy i had a guy
you'll like this i'm sitting this is
where this is
maybe like five years ago i'm sitting on
the 101
um
six it was before my daughter 101 right
around laurel canyon going toward
hollywood okay it's bumper to bumper i'm
not moving i'm in a a cherokee a jeep
cherokee
and um all of a sudden this [ __ ] car
what i think is a car hits me from
behind i'm like us you know not paying
attention probably texting we're all
creeping
and then i look up my rear view and
there's a line of cars as if they're
starting a race that are a good 30 yards
behind me but they're all right there
and everyone on the freeway is now
stopped and everyone else in front of me
is gone i'm like what the [ __ ] is going
on and i look at my side view and i see
a motorcycle rider down he's running to
me trying to split the lane but i did
not i was sitting still i didn't wasn't
my fault but the guy crashes i'm like oh
holy [ __ ] and everyone is i get out on
the freeway we're not pulled to the side
and i'm like dude are you okay he's like
help me pick up my bike i'm like are you
okay i don't think you should get up are
you okay help me get my bike to the side
i'm okay so i pull my car over and i
help him get the bike to the side and
then it's just like [ __ ] them and here
goes everybody everybody and we're out
there like when i'm still helping him
they're flying by us 70 miles an hour
we're in the lane so the guys i'm like
are you okay you know can i call 9-1-1
he's like i think i'm okay um and he he
gets on his bike he's like let me just
see if this thing works and the
[ __ ] starts it and takes off
and i'm like dude and i'm yelling at him
because
i i think he's definitely concussed
right but probably on drugs or something
from the night before i'm guessing too
he's probably in shock i'm in shock and
he just takes off and i can't chase him
or follow him because he's splitting
lanes and gone i was like [ __ ]
you're insane dude probably didn't have
insurance probably just getting the [ __ ]
out of there right yeah and that's why
yeah yeah i tell my kids i'll be like
look you're not doing it while you're
living here uh that's what my dad used
to say and they're not under my roof
it's my house but uh but i was like just
so you know i mean i was like it's cool
i get it it's the freedom all that ride
free
all that but a pothole
that when i hit a pothole in quadruple
egypt yeah in the land cruiser or even
the porsche i'll be like
i'll be my phone call will not be
interrupted uh or even when i hit him
out here i'm like damn even in a car i'm
like dude yeah like damn and that's the
end of it but if you hit that on a
motorcycle your life could change yeah
forever and
i was like you may never use your leg
properly again after that that's right
you're gonna smack your head and so
uh yeah i i gotta hand it to them
i've so i'd rather start smoking
that's probably less dangerous yeah yeah
probably um but your son is okay now has
no
he's good to go can he play sports can
he do all the things oh he's got yeah no
he's the the only thing he has to do
yeah is there anything you have to be
careful the only thing you have to do is
like
early on in his life you take
antibiotics before you go to the dentist
uh because you're when you when you free
plaque it can
somehow like i don't think it like in
theory it could i don't know how it i
don't know how it works but that was
what we had to do uh he is on the autism
spectrum so he's a very uh not typical
kid uh not interested in sports uh he
does like the seahawks thank god um
so we've gone to a few games but um
but yeah very different kid and he's
like it's gonna be my size
oh he is a big kid yeah he's already
he's already i don't know he's probably
six feet now damn is he really yeah so
he's [ __ ] he's big uh as a big kid um
and my 13 year old's also going to be
big so um all right so this is
interesting your son is 16 now right
yeah all right so i i mentioned before
we started that uh first time guests i
always ask them advice
yes that you would give to your 16 year
old self so buy a motorcycle
[Laughter]
i mean this could really be advice
you're giving not only to you but your
son as well i mean he's exactly that age
right now what would you say oh what
what would i say
to me to sixteen-year-old joel mchale
what would you say right now what's the
benefit of heinz stop jumping off [ __ ]
why didn't you
yeah no i was i i've had like
six seven concussions and a skull
fracture have you really yeah from what
you jumping and shooting ironically i
played football and i didn't really ever
get a true concussion playing football
yes did i get my bell rung and did every
practice i felt slightly drunk at the
end so yes i did but like the number of
times that i was like i'm gonna jump off
this roof and smack my head dumb [ __ ]
and then i fracture my skull skiing
which i don't i still i don't have a
memory of the day but so that's not like
i don't have this like hey
breathe okay
take time to enjoy you know i don't have
that but i was like don't jump off [ __ ]
all right uh
and um i'm trying to think of advice
that i would be nice
yeah be nice be nice that's great advice
yeah just be nice to everybody well dude
thank you so much for coming on thank
you ryan talking about that um honeydew
yeah um will you please promote whatever
you'd like again everything i'm going to
be in baltimore on uh september 30th
at the uh
where are you where are you playing in
baltimore the famous you're not where
i'm at trust me oh i i i guarantee we'd
be at the same places
uh how many seats is that 300. that's
how many shows you're doing
one now but if it sells i'll do another
so uh
uh i'm i guess watch star girl watch
crime scene kids girl on it's on uh the
cw
but it's on the dc app i think that's
where most people get it it's very
popular with teenagers and teenage gals
but i get to work with uh great cast but
luke wilson's on it with enemy smarts on
it and
working with him is like i i like i'm a
big gaming sport but luke wilson was in
the royal tandem bombs yeah
and bottle rock and old school yeah and
i people forget about him in old school
he's amazing guy in old school i mean
idiot idiocracy a masterpiece and i
after knowing him for a bit i was just
like hey just so you know i'm a gigantic
fan yeah like when do you when he's like
oh
okay
you got it yeah okay
sure buddy great
big fan that's good oh yeah i heard all
about it so uh yeah what else i don't
know i'm doing some stand up
uh yeah so i'm gonna yeah i'm uh i'm
trying to think of anything yeah so just
yeah uh yo cbl.com
for dates
updates live there all right it's great
thank you again no ryan thank you you
are a seriously thoughtful person thank
you my man um and as always ryan sickler
all social media ryan sickler.com we'll
talk to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you